I've been checking my glucose a bit after I wake up every morning for the last week,
but it has been between 89 and 107.
Hey, I think I spoke about this a little bit last week. 89,
yeah, that's better. 107, that's not good. But I'll talk more about that. I noticed that on days,
I take it at 8 a.m. It's over 100. On days, I take it at 9. It's around 90. This is the total
number for me over the years, but I haven't eaten so clean, low-carb, doing intermittent fasting,
constantly. Could the hormone blocking medications on increase my glucose, and or cortisol,
insulin, and cause these higher numbers? Possibly, there's probably not a lot of research data
about that, but there are any things possible, as far as usually the drug. So that is possible.
I haven't eliminated carbs completely, but only eats sparingly foods like berries, apples,
and a slice of the zikil bread ever done by dinners. And there's no correlation,
example, the morning after I had some culverse chocolate custard and a glass of wine as a treat,
it was only 92. I've told my new oncologist's office, I'm not taking another rejection or
pill until I get my usual full-bud pen, it'll start. I will ask them if this is a side effect,
but what do they get your opinion? Well, they probably will tell you, you're better off just
a line search if that's a side effect, but I would highly doubt that that would you
find that anywhere? It's probably really hasn't been studied.
So back to getting your glucose levels down, this is going to be the most common thing
when you're talking about glucose levels, says, hey, my glucose is 92 no better, what I do,
I can't seem to bunch that. Well, sorry, but this is just life. Your glucose levels,
yes, have to do with what you eat, but it has more to do with your
cells and the cell membranes ability to receive that glucose and get inside the cells.
And the longer we live, the more exposed that exposure we have to toxins that damage our cell
membranes, and then reproducing cells with damaged cell membranes, the less
more compromise that we have with our ability of our cells to receive glucose, I mean, you need
glucose in a daily life, in order for it to break down through glycolysis, for you to make ATP,
and then through glycolysis to acetylcodes, and the A to go into the Krebs cycle for you to
kick out a ton of ATP, ATP is energy. So it's not just your muscles that need it, that's how
every cellular function that you have is is reliant is dependent upon ATP. So
and that's where as we age, our pancreas isn't making insulin as well, we've come more insulin
resistant, our cell membranes become insulin resistant, and our cell membranes become more
damaged and less healthy, and the glucose-receiving receptors don't work as well, so it's not as easy.
You know, if you were 23 years older, you decided to start fast eating and clean up your diet,
you could probably take somebody who has an average glucose of 107, and get them down to
in the 80s within a week as we age, it's just sometimes impossible. I've had people that come
to me for diabetes, they don't have cancer, their glucose is in the 200s, we put them on a super,
super strict diet almost, a ketogenic diet, and it seems to do absolutely nothing for their glucose
levels. The reason is, is if your glucose is at 200, and it's diabetes, and
diabetes is just a neighborhood disease that means that your glucose receptors on your cell
membranes have been so damaged. Now, you could also have, a person can also have type 1 diabetes
is completely different, and that is an autoimmune disease of the eyelid cell, so the pancreas where you're
not able to make insulin, and that's totally different situation.